Nintendo is back despite a string of
dark days the classic gaming company has
recently come around to giving diehard
fans what they've truly wanted for years
mobile games like Pokemon go a new entry
into the Zelda franchise and the great
specs that will be packed into their
upcoming NX system they've even finally
started to reach out to classic gamers
with their upcoming mini NES packed with
30 vintage games
it's a renaissance for the flagging
company looking back it's not the first
time they avoided total ruination here
are a few of the biggest mistakes in
Nintendo's history Virtual Boy the
poster child for Nintendo's boneheaded
ideas Virtual Boy launched in 1995 and
was completely discontinued within a
year to use it gamers plant their faces
into a stationary viewing port and play
games with an external controller while
red LEDs simulate a parallax 3d
environment within the system all of
this was years after Nintendo had begun
using better 3d tag on games like Star
Fox Nintendo was forced to remove the
virtual reality like head tracking
feature before the virtual boys released
due to health concerns which may have
made the system's reception even worse
only 22 Virtual Boy games were released
and Nintendo seems to maintain their
regret to this day mostly because they
were twenty years too early powerglove
even deeper in Nintendo's history is the
terrible power glove a sweaty mess of
plastic from 1990 that players strapped
on to their arms and desperately tried
to control through a grand total of two
dedicated games programmable finger
motions make the power glove sound like
it might be a fun novelty but making
Mario jump by flashing double horns or
poking at your arm with your one free
hand proved too cumbersome of an
alternate control scheme for most games
and the two games that specifically
utilized on the device just weren't fun
enough to make the power glove a
successful peripheral plus it made you
look like a gigantic nerd SNES CD it's a
story right out of Mega Man or something
Nintendo built their own arch-nemesis
back in the late 80s Nintendo was
already looking at CD technology to
pants they're Super Nintendo and began
to work with Sony on the prospective
console legend has it that Sony wasn't
previously interested in entering the
video game market but after a few years
of working with Nintendo and getting
nowhere fast
they repurposed the work they'd already
done and revealed the PlayStation at an
electronic show in 1991 at the same time
Nintendo revealed their partnership with
Philips which eventually resulted in the
epically awful CDI system and its
legendary Zelda games
gee it sure is boring around here Sony
and Nintendo never made peace and the
PlayStation eventually overtook Nintendo
as the console of choice for serious
gamers one good thing did result however
the Secret of Mana developed originally
for the CDI was ported to the SNES and
remains one of the best RPGs of all time
ereader
a peripheral for the Game Boy Advance
the e-reader could scan tiny barcodes on
the edge of specific trading cards
collect the data and either use that
information to augment an existing game
or load up a classic NES game the device
was relatively popular in Japan and
received support for about six years but
the whole thing tanked in the u.s. after
just two the e-reader often had
difficulty reading codes and scanning 10
cards to run Excitebike never really
caught on
especially when cartridges that did the
exact same thing were readily available
even the inclusion of barcodes on
popular Pokemon trading cards wasn't
enough to make the e-reader seem cool
64dd the worst ever commercial failure
for nintendo was the 64dd a disk drive
designed to attach to the Nintendo 64
the 64dd suffered four years of delays
before finally releasing in 1999 only in
Japan the device promised to be a hub
for buying nintendo stuff on a
proprietary network a place to share
content with other gamers a music
listening station and all manner of
other interactive things ultimately only
15,000 units sold because a 28 k modem
and magnetic 64 megabyte discs have
never really been enough to keep
anything alive ignoring mobile gaming
even though Nintendo and AI antics
Pokemon go broke all kinds of mobile
gaming records Nintendo was excruciating
slow and getting into the app market
according to Forbes Nintendo owns 4,000
mobile gaming patents which they're now
poised to use but Nintendo's former CEO
Satoru Iwata who passed away in 2015 had
previously repeatedly shot down the idea
of Nintendo entering the mobile market
and gadget collected a WADA's quotes
which include quotes if we did this
Nintendo would cease to be Nintendo and
quote
Avada also said that free games just
don't offer the level of fun that
dedicated console games could and were
pumped out for quantity and not quality
Nintendo acknowledged that they were
missing out on profits by ignoring the
market but continued to shun it anyhow
by 2014 a WOD as stance began to change
but Nintendo was already many years
behind other developers the Nintendo
creators program
watching people play video games has
become a huge business but Nintendo is
the only company to become territorial
over the use of their games in
derivative media at one point Nintendo
and YouTube divided all revenue
generated by fan made videos but things
changed when Nintendo announced their
Nintendo creators program
under the terms of the program creators
actually get a small percentage of their
own ad revenue but only under a slew of
oppressive terms and conditions Nintendo
has to approve the video as
representative of their brand so all
negative reviews are out this means that
Nintendo is essentially only approving
free commercials for their products
Nintendo can also claim ownership of any
video they approve and youtubers can
only make videos about specific games it
all falls under a very sticky area of
fair use but it completely falls under
making Nintendo look like an evil final
boss Wii U even though plenty of we use
are in use the system is still regarded
as a huge commercial failure when
compared to its main competitors not to
mention its immediate predecessor the
Wii there are hundreds of small reasons
why the Wii U hasn't done well but
gamers just can't take the system
seriously without a new Zelda or Metroid
game available there's a weird
touchscreen tablet control scheme
that few games successfully overcome and
the tablet controller itself has a
pathetic battery life the only real
killer app Mario maker has a very
specific audience it seems unlikely that
the Wii U will actually take off before
the next Nintendo system emerges thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which mistakes you think
Nintendo has made